>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, DC.
>> David Phylar: Good
evening everybody,
thanks so much for
being here tonight.
I'm very excited about
tonight's concert.
I've been listening to the
rehearsals and everything.
It's sounding really great,
so you're in for a real treat.
But I'm also very grateful
and excited to be joined
by composer Brian Ferneyhough,
who is here and is the recipient
of the commission work that will
receive it's world premier tonight.
And also the conductor
of Talea, James Baker.
And so we're just going to have
a conversation about the piece
and about some other things
and see where that goes,
but there will also be some
time at the end for you
to ask any questions
that you might have.
So please bear those in mind.
So maybe just a starting point, what
can you tell us about the piece?
[laughter]
>> Brian Ferneyhough: You want
me to give it away in advance?
[laughter] Well, first of all,
thank you, David, for the commission
for the Library of Congress.
It's a great [inaudible].
I've never been here
in Washington before,
and so it was very interesting
to walk around a little bit today
and get some feel for the
atmosphere of the building,
which is quite extraordinary
of course.
Let me start answering this
question by citing another composer,
Arnold Schoenberg, who has
many works I think lodged here
and was commissioned also by the
Library of Congress in his time.
He wrote a book called Style and
Idea, and style is fairly clear.
You can statistically
ascertain, for instance,
if a play was by Shakespeare
or perhaps by somebody else
and then put under his name because
there are stylist discrepancies.
So style is fine, but idea
is a very strange word
when you apply it to the arts.
We don't know in fact,
although books have been written
on the topic, whether he was
talking about a musical motif,
about a way of treating
musical motifs.
We don't know if it was
concrete musical material at all.
Some of his pieces clearly weren't.
I mean, things like Erwartung or Die
gluckliche Hand, the operatic works,
clearly had a fundamental idea
which by and large I suppose came
from a mixture of expressionism
and Freudian psychology.
But for a composer today,
it's an issue which is
fraught with problems.
The idea of a piece of music
expressing, incorporating,
articulating an idea or a set
of ideas is problematic simply
because music, although we
can treat it like a language,
probably is not a language.
It doesn't have the semantic context
that an everyday language has.
We can't point to things
in music by and large,
which relate to something
outside music,
which can be related back
to the inside of music.
So one of the things
that's concerned me
over the years has
been the idea indeed
of how much one may derive the
nature of a piece of music from sort
of act of prior conceptualization,
yes?
And over the years, I've done this.
I started composing some from
the late '50's and by the time
of the mid '60's, early
'70's, I was writing works
which in some way tried to reflect
bodies of ideas, if you like,
intellectual or [inaudible]
disciplines.
They could be historic.
They could be philosophical.
They could be something else
indeed, poetry or what have you,
but I've always felt that
contemporary music suffers
in many respects by being the
art which does not relate easily
to the everyday sensations,
which we are a party to.
And so we find contemporary
music more difficult to enter
into precisely because we have
to make certain presuppositions,
which A, we are not on the
whole used to doing, and B,
without knowing if
those presuppositions
that one's making have anything
to do with that piece, in reality.
So, I've always looked to see if I
can find something in other areas,
which one can, one can focus
on, one can sit on or stand on,
one can circle around it, rather
like an artificial flat earth,
which is sitting on
top of a tortoise,
top of an elephant.
[laughter] Of course these
things are always not [inaudible]
arbitrary, but these things are
a reflection of one's own unease
about the means with
which one works.
And part of the drama of
contemporary music in my view
at least since the '70's perhaps
has been understanding how much the
sociology of musical
creation is involved
in the actual creation
of musical works.
Many works have for instance some
sort of improvisatory aspects
to them, which implies that
the person performing the work,
the mediator, is aware of the
unspoken criteria of rectitude,
if you like, which he has to apply
to an authentic performance
of the work.
And so most of my work,
certainly the last ten years,
have been based upon
ideas of this [inaudible],
which can in part be
transcribed into musical means,
but you all know program music.
Richard Strauss' Alpensinfonie,
where you go up a mountain,
the sun comes out at
midday, you came down,
there are sheep [inaudible]
in the meadows.
Yes, that is program music, or
earlier [inaudible] or [inaudible].
All these things are based upon
musically external formal markers.
Now this is something I try
to distance myself from.
Well you can't do it entirely.
Okay. This piece, [foreign
language].
Why Italian?
Well it sounds good in Italian.
[laughter] And if I were to put
it in German, [foreign language],
it would have implications
about the [inaudible] and lately
of the philosophy of [inaudible] and
his near Marxian sort of rhetoric.
All right [inaudible]
entirely out of the ballpark.
Nevertheless, I obviously
don't want people to have
to have the presupposition of the
listening and reading philosophy
in order to hear my music.
It's not, it's not sounding
philosophy in any means at all,
although I might [inaudible]
otherwise 40 years ago,
I don't know.
Yes, so English, the [inaudible]
word [foreign language] I guess the
word most of you would
be, what is the word now.
>> Rebound.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Rebound.
Recoil. I think that's
the word, yes.
And it's in fact a lot of
things in music attempt
to take different musical
objects or ways of working,
bringing them together,
and in so doing,
create a sort of third synthesis,
which demonstrates the skill
of the composer and also
provides unexpected perspectives
for the listener who has
followed the process [inaudible].
However, this piece implies
not a sort of dialectal process
of that sort, A, B, A,
B, sometimes mixed up.
What it does is present you with
two sometimes crassly opposed types
of musical [inaudible], and each of
these types of [inaudible] develop
in its particular way over
the course of the piece,
but [inaudible] take
incognizance of what the other sort
of material is doing since they
are always placed together.
There are joined together
with very sudden breaks.
So one of the problems I had with
writing this piece, I always think
of myself as a fairly, fairly
adequate formalist, but of course,
the idea of taking two
totally different things,
sticking them one next to the other
over the course of a piece, A, B,
A1, B1, and so on,
really was something
which I was not particularly
easy with in my own soul,
and so that was a challenge, but
also it was a challenge not to give
in to attempting to make
these things so similar
that they would be [inaudible]
that I could show my skill
because these things didn't
offer any recoil, any resistance,
and it's the offering of resistance
of these things to each other,
each in its own way of
progression throughout the work,
which is basically forms
the idea of the composition,
apart from the beginning.
The beginning has 12 little
sort of things, resonance.
So you've always got one
type of thing, resonance,
another type of thing, resonance,
and the ending is a much
expanded version of that,
so we do have these
sort of formalists,
you might almost call
them traditionalist,
[inaudible] with respect to how
pieces may begin and pieces may end.
But it really was difficult for
me to write a piece precisely
because each of these things has
its own demands to be placed on me.
For instance, one of the major
constraints of the first type
of material is that it's
all built around piano.
So you've got piano plus, piano
plus plus, piano all in double base.
And whilst the registers of
these things are always changing
and the density of the materials
which are being sort of revolved,
like a revolving door, are
being brought round and round
in a canonic sort of game.
This sort of thing was
entirely unappropriate
to the other type of material.
So the other type of material
is defined [inaudible].
In other words, you'd
say, oh, this, yes,
this is this because
it's not something else.
And it's an extremely weak thesis
to basically entirely
compositional, but it does work.
I mean very often we recognize
that we don't recognize something.
So what you will be hearing in this
particular piece is not an attempt
to create a global synthesis between
two however created, however molded
and manipulated [inaudible], but
it's a very, very provisional
but insistent attempt to lock
them into some sort of interplay,
reactive interplay with each
other, which does not involve them
in taking on the characteristics
of its opposite number.
>> David Phylar: One
followup question
to that contragolpeous
[phonetic] to that question,
that's just a throughout of that
[inaudible], would be you mentioned
with respect to program
music, and there's an element
of composer fiat that's
involved when you're titling,
an so is the title
more about any sort
of programmatic component might
be, it's indication of a process.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well this is,
and that's why I put in the language
which comes, is not everyday
language for many people.
Most of my titles are
not in English.
Those of my titles
that are in English,
I've taken from obscure
poetic sources.
So there's always a sort of
second level behind these things.
And I leave people to puzzle.
If you know any Italian, you know
first of all [inaudible], but yes,
against blows, yes, okay.
But if you think there is
recoil, something bangs
up against something else,
which is somewhat intransigent,
and it bounces off, it
gets bent in the process.
And if this bending of both
materials to accommodate a sort
of energy and trajectory
of [inaudible],
which is really what the expression
of the work in my mind is all about.
>> David Phylar: Well one of
the, again, I've only a chance
to hear it just a bit in
rehearsal, but one of the things
that really struck me was with
respect to the bending is the use
of steel drums with the keyboard.
The interplay is really beautiful,
and you'll enjoy it very much,
but you get this, just a
wonderful sense of it kind
of exploring this inter-realm in
terms of just what's happening
versus the rest of the composition.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well,
I use the piano [inaudible] has
an electric keyboard as well
as a piano, and since the piano is
at the center of these first types
of material which keep
on going around,
the other sections
don't use normal piano.
They use a piano keyboard with
piano sounds but tuned in third
and sixth tones, so they are by
and large belonging to a sort
of alien universe of expression.
You'll particularly hear this at the
end of a piece where I put delivery
with normal pictures and
then the same rhythms
in these microtonal
[inaudible] underneath.
So that's the first thing
that I've never done before,
and the second thing,
yes, the steel drums.
Lovely instruments.
I've never used those before either.
You know, as you get older, it's
good as a young man or woman
for that matter no doubt, to keep
a couple of instruments in reserve.
[laughter] A harp was one of those.
Guitar was certainly one
of those 20 years ago.
I suppose some instruments
just don't fit very well
into the contemporary music
context like a cornetta [phonetic]
or a serpent or something
or a [inaudible]
but the steel drums are [inaudible]
and perfectly consistent
within themselves.
I expected them to be must
more crass than they are.
They are extremely
subtle-sounding objects,
and the players said this was the
first time they're actually trying
to build these things into
a composition I understand.
>> David Phylar: Well, you know,
one other thing that struck me
and then I'll move onto maybe James
has some, talk about the process
of putting together the work, one
thing that I was also hearing is
that there is quite a bit
of not just things moving
against each other but
also some, I don't know how
to describe them except
as maybe moments of stasis
or [inaudible] pedal points almost,
or gestural pedal points that are--
are those types of kind
of connective tissues
or are those also more
just extrapolations
of a particular [inaudible].
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well, I
promised I wouldn't get into--
>> David Phylar: Okay, [inaudible].
>> Brian Ferneyhough: They're not
put there as it were to allow you
to refresh your palate [inaudible].
I don't know if [inaudible]
comparisons [inaudible] of any sort,
but they arise by virtue
of the processes
which I'm applying [inaudible].
It may be in some sections
there are more notes there
because I cut fewer notes out.
One long note may be there
because I cut out all the notes
which would have been around
it by following a sort of,
some sort of intellectual
[inaudible].
And a lot of things that I do in my
music start out as a tremendous sort
of bustle of materials like the
rhythmic structures of this work,
22 layers and they go on for
140 pages [inaudible] 140 pages.
[laughter] Then I find
secondary procedures to them,
which either brings
out particularity
of the rhythmic process at that
moment on that level or seeks
to obscure it by eliminating it
compared with something else.
So really that's what's happening
is [inaudible] you've got a sort
of mental rubber as you're rubbing
out things, and you are meant
to feel time differently, because
when time is filling itself
up with lots of activity,
that's one thing,
but when that activity disappears
and time is left in a sort
of naked form as a polyphonic sort
of counter entity with the material,
that's the moment when we
perceive time most [inaudible],
and that's always been
something that fascinates me.
>> David Phylar: Well the work
is clearly a very difficult work
to put together but it seems like
it's so effortless to the ensemble.
It seems that they're doing
a really fantastic job for me
and from the outside,
and I'm just wondering
about that process of
putting it together.
How do you get started on a work
like this when you receive it.
>> James Baker: Well, yeah,
it's, on the page it looks,
it looks extremely difficult.
There are aspects of it that could
be daunting to look at just in terms
of sort of the varied rhythms upon
rhythms that need to be revealed
in the rehearsal process,
but the, you know,
the members of the group are just,
they're so good, and so smart,
and so prepared that at the first
rehearsal it's possible just
to steam, full steam ahead and
really work on the things that I
from studying feel that
I need to accomplish.
And I'm, you know, it's, I don't,
I try to analyze the
piece as much as I can.
Obviously I can't get into the
mind of the composer completely
or even nearly in terms of, you
know, really all the procedures,
procedural stuff, but, you know,
Brian writes such beautiful phrases,
and the ideas of section
stuff, sectional architecture,
the way that the piano reveals
each time the new section
or the electric keyboard as he
said, you know, those are the kind
of things that are, and then the
materials as there are, you know,
the dual materials
that are happening
and then [inaudible] back up again.
I mean those are things that I
can, that I can see very clearly
and then there are
rhythmic things that I need
to make sure are together.
There are pitch things that I
want to make sure that I tune,
that everyone's aware of
when pitch is coming together
or coming apart [inaudible],
so there, you know,
there are all these just, those
are all just basic musical nuts
and bolts things that we
are, that's what we do.
>> David Phylar: Sure, sure.
>> James Baker: So they're,
fortunately they're so prepared
that it makes it very easy.
Now once a composer
enters the picture,
then things are even more
revealed from his point of view.
He can really talk to us about
his process and the things
that really need to be
more carefully taken care
of that I may have just--
>> David Phylar: Is there
any sort of a general thing
that you might say about when
Bryan entered that conversation,
what sorts of things
came to the fore?
>> James Baker: Well I think he's
particularly eloquent about what he,
what he's done, what he's
made, and what he needs to hear
from what is on the page.
Some composers are very obtuse,
you know, or less than able
to even communicate with the group,
but his, he has an amazing ability
to tell me exactly what I need to
find the character or find the--
those things are, those
things are important.
>> Brian Ferneyhough:
[Inaudible] a work of this size,
it's not [inaudible] the
number of instruments,
it's peculiarly sensitive to the
performers knowing what's going on.
If you're in a string
quartet, you work together
and you discuss things, and you come
to a liberated interpretation
on that basis.
But if you've got say
10 or 12 performers,
it's neither chamber
music nor orchestra.
>> James Baker: Yeah.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: And
the composer has to take note
of that and act accordingly.
>> James Baker: And it's good
for us to know what he needed
to hear in terms of balance.
You know, our sense of four or
five P's up to three, you know,
to three F's, that space, how
it's filled, he was very helpful
in saying like this is what my
idea of 3P is at this point.
This is the voice that
I need to hear
and how the balance should work.
He is very helpful in balancing.
>> David Phylar: Did you feel that
there was much adaptation that had
to be done to your approach
to playing it once you
arrived in Washington.
>> James Baker: Well,
we've slowed it
down a little bit I think
because of the room.
The room is so bright and so,
and I think it's good
exercise for me because I tend
sometimes with slow tempos I tend
to be a little on the fast side,
which is a bad habit that I am
getting into as I get older I think,
but I used to be proud of
being able to do music slowly,
but I'm getting worse at
it, I think [laughter].
But I mean it's really,
we've expanded out,
and it feels really nice, I mean I
feel like we opened things up more.
In New York, you know, the
rehearsal studio we have is,
it's nice to have a rehearsal
studio in New York City,
that's your home dedicated space.
I would never put that down, but
it's a very, it's a smallish,
very strident, ugly,
ugly room [laughter].
And the piano we have is not
a very good instrument, etc.,
etc. Those kinds of things.
And so to get in here
in a beautiful room
with a beautiful piano
that's making, you know,
that's generating is
one of the things
that we need to have to generate.
It just, it makes it a little
different piece, so it's a pleasure
to do it in a room like
that, that's for sure.
>> David Phylar: I'm wondering if I
can take a step back for a moment.
I heard an anecdote earlier
today about a performance
of Cassandra's Dream Song in which
you demonstrated on the flute,
and so I guess I'm wondering
if you could say a few words
about your experience as a former
[inaudible] and how that impacted.
>> Brian Ferneyhough:
Well it's strange really.
The flute has always
been an instrument
that I've written most
for, I suppose,
[inaudible] there have been, I don't
know, seven or eight [inaudible]
or piece with significant
flute in it anyway.
I never had a lesson in
my life on the flute.
I learned it, I picked
it up myself at school.
There was a heap of
military band equipment,
which my music teacher had
piled, he used to be the director
of the lyrical band in
the wartime circumstances,
and he piled all these
instruments, which were broken.
They were sometimes old with
half the keys missing [inaudible]
or models which no longer
were being built anyway.
And I went in there, and I took
a flute, and I took an oboe,
and I took a clarinet, and
I stuck them together again,
and I repaired them.
I put rubber bands where
I couldn't find springs.
And I started learning to play them.
And the reason that,
well, this funny thing
about Cassandra Dream Song, this is
my first flute solo piece I wrote
in 1970, I had just moved
from England to Switzerland.
I was living in the town of Basel.
And I only had a very
small room, of course.
I was a graduate student at
that time in the [inaudible],
and the flute was the
only instrument
that realistically I
could take with me.
No piano, no trumpet, which was my
other instrument, and so when I came
to start a new piece it was
obvious that I did on the basis
of the instrument that
I had available,
and I could work everything out.
And in fact, it was
that particular piece,
you shouldn't be too impressed
by my picking up the instrument
and playing it for someone else,
it's the only one of my flute pieces
that in fact I could ever play.
[laughter]
>> David Phylar: Did that
knowledge kind of set the tone
for how you would approach dealing,
coming to intimate knowledge
of each instrument that you
write for, because it seems
like that's just something
that you very clearly possess.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well you can't
write difficult music unless you
know what the degree of difficulty
is that you're asking people
to deal with, both the
conductor and the performers.
If you can't tell an oboe
player or a trombone player,
try this position instead
of that position,
it means you haven't done
your homework essentially,
and many things, by learning
instrumental technique very
precisely, many things become
available, become opened up to you,
that wouldn't have been obvious
if you just followed the
basic trail most travelled.
>> David Phylar: I think one thing
that I'm always just interested
in asking composers is what they're
up to now and what they might be,
what's on the horizon, and maybe
there's another theatrical operatic
work, and, you know, that sort--
>> Brian Ferneyhough:
What am I doing?
Well, at my age it's probably
not good to ask people
to look too far into the future.
I'm doing a piece based upon a
re-reading of the [inaudible]
of Christopher Tye, English
Renaissance composer.
And I'm going to do 10 of those.
I've done several already.
Each of which will approach
the original material,
the [inaudible] in a different way.
The interesting thing is that these
[inaudible] are totally motile
[phonetic], they are not
grammatic in any way.
They don't fit in with
my musical ideas at all.
So it has been challenging
for me to make each one
of these little pieces, and
it's re-reading of the original
if I am using [inaudible],
examine different aspects
of the original than
one might expect.
For instance, the one I'm
doing now is for solo cello,
and what I did was, the
only thing that I take
from the original is the innominate
dominate [phonetic] thing,
which [inaudible], and I
counted up all the notes
that occurred [inaudible]
so a lot of notes.
And I counted up all the notes
in every measure, and the number
of notes in every measure went from
three to like 17 and back again.
I used that as an input instruction
for how many notes would follow one
of the innominate dominate pitches.
So you get a pitch, and then you
get a flurry of other pitches,
it doesn't matter how
they're created,
say 15 because that
measure has 15 notes in it.
Now that's got nothing to
do whatsoever with the music
of Christopher Tye apart from
in a very, very density way,
as you know with polyphonic
music of that sort,
it will start with a few notes.
It will build up, typically
I measured 30 or something
to a very high density and
then it will fall off again
to a slightly less
density at the end,
and these things happen
all the time.
So at least I knew that I
would have a sort of curve
of densities to work with.
>> David Phylar: So
what seemed like a,
might seem like an arbitrary
thing actually has this very clear
projection into what the
possibilities are as your--
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Yeah,
and every one of the pieces
does something different,
so it's like one of those old,
those old pinball machines.
If you're very skilled at it,
you can get more money out of it
or points out of it
than everybody else.
And that's what we try to do.
We try to, composers try to
created elevated pinball machines.
[laughter].
>> David Phylar: What's your
favorite pinball machine?
[laughter]
>> Brian Ferneyhough: No,
actually I am not a gambler myself.
>> David Phylar: Is there a
chance that you'll be working
on another theatrical
project down the road,
another opera or something along--
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Nobody's asked
me for one, and nobody had asked me
for one when I sat down
to write my first one.
I have to explain that my first
one was like 10 years ago,
and it was a piece called
Shadowtime, and it was in fact done
in New York around that period.
And it deals with the life and death
of the German Jewish
philosopher, Walter Benjamin.
He has always been someone I've
felt some sort of affinity for.
He was a very chaotic individual in
his life, if not in his thinking.
And, I was always proud of the fact
that this opera is probably
the only one ever written
in which the main character dies
at the end of the first scene.
And his avatar, or his
spirit, wanders the underworld
in various ways thereafter.
So, what is an opera,
well that's the question.
I was asked by the Munich
Biennale to write a piece,
and they commissioned me on the
opera, so I said, okay, opera, yes.
But you know, many many of
the early theater works,
things like [inaudible]
of the Florentine court
and things like that.
They were written, that
was a collaborative action
by several composers.
Some guy wrote the ballet,
some guy wrote the songs.
You have to do it that way
otherwise you'd never do it.
And there were a lot of religious
[inaudible] which boarder
on the dramatic in the conventional
sense even though the characters
have names like Virtue or
Spite or something like that.
So I think the interesting thing
about opera for me is not opera
as such but the idea that you
can, you put a theater of the mind
and this theater of the
mind can be illuminated
with a feeble torch perhaps
or even just a match.
That Helmut Lachenmann's Little
Match Girl just [whooshing noise]
the sound of a match, illuminating.
It was the structure
of the whole piece.
So, yeah, I said I wouldn't write an
opera because I didn't know anything
about human beings, but luckily
the human beings were all dead
so [laughter].
I don't know what, that doesn't
answer your question, I'm sorry.
I don't know.
I might be interested
in doing a chamber one.
This was a very big one.
I might be interested in
doing something which rather
like [inaudible] has four or five
players and four to five singers.
>> David Phylar: One of the, I mean,
you had an interesting
collaboration [inaudible] one
of the poetry [inaudible].
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Ah, yes.
The very well-known poet, Charles
Bernstein, is a friend of mine.
He kindly agreed to write
the lyrics for this piece
under the stringent rules
that I am imposed upon him.
One of those rules that every line
must have this number of syllables
and no more and no less,
so there were patterns.
Also, words in principle
should be permutable,
that you could change the
order of words in a line
and still have some
sense come out of it.
And the third, the third
constraint was that he would be able
to publish it as a
book, because you know
so many opera techs are
shamefully illiterate.
Maybe it just belongs to the genre,
but some of them are
really, really, really bad.
Like a lot of the texts used
[inaudible], hey lasso [phonetic].
So I wanted it to be poetry
that he would feel comfortable
about in spite of me imposing
these limitations upon him,
and indeed he did do it.
>> David Phylar: I think before
we get to taking some questions
from the audience,
you're playing this,
you're performing this
work again fairly soon
in New York, is that right?
>> James Baker: Yes,
next Wednesday night.
>> David Phylar: What type
of space, what kind of a,
what kind of a situation is
that compared to this and--
>> James Baker: It's in a theater
in Brooklyn I think called Roulette,
which is a pretty good sized room.
It's a ball, I think it
was a ballroom in a hotel
at one point or something.
It has the [inaudible] that goes
around and a floor for seating,
for seating of the type that is
extended out to hold larger groups.
So it's not as big.
I don't think it holds as many
people as this auditorium,
but it's not a small
space, and I'm hoping
that they don't do what
they normally do there,
which is they have
this alarming tendency
to amplify everything slightly.
Everything, no matter what.
And I'm trying to hope that
they don't, to find out,
to try to make them not do that.
>> David Phylar: I hope you don't
have to fight against impulse.
>> James Baker: Yeah, that's
an impulse that's out there,
it's just really disconcerting.
It turns into a really, it turns
into a nightmare very quickly.
>> David Phylar: Oh sure, sure.
>> James Baker: For those of us
that, I mean, you know, I love the,
I love amplified music, but I, you
know, if you deal most strictly
with acoustic music, it's just
a, it's just a, it's a horror.
So--
>> David Phylar: Well we're so
pleased that, that it's going
to have a second performance
[inaudible] following the first--
>> James Baker: Oh, yeah, no,
we're looking forward to it.
I mean it's always great to be able
to play something that you work
so hard on, you know, as
many times as possible.
I hope this piece is, I hope
we give it a ball of life--
>> David Phylar: It
has a chance to grow--
>> James Baker: Oh,
yeah, absolutely.
I mean it's already starting to feel
a little more organic, you know,
with just a few run throughs,
you know, in the last few days,
so hopefully that will
just continue.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well it has
to get to the point where instead
of saying [inaudible] 67 and not
63, you say it goes like this.
In other words, the conductor
himself is not thinking
in these rigorous ratio
relationships [inaudible] baseline,
but you know how music goes.
>> James Baker: Exactly, right.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: It's
just a little shorthand
to actual personal
reliving forth as it were--
>> James Baker: Yeah.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: --
and what's in the material.
>> James Baker: And for
me it because really,
it really becomes a physical, I feel
it in body, I feel it in my bones,
I feel the movement, I feel
the piece move in my body,
and once I get to the place where
it feels right, and it's right
with Brian, then I,
that's a good feeling.
>> David Phylar: Right, I'm sure.
Well, why don't we
take some questions
from the audience, anybody?
We have a microphone
that'll come to you.
>> Thank you very much.
Your comments, all three of your
comments were very interesting.
Especially because the Library has
a new, a new practice of sending
out the program notes
the day or before,
and I notice that you did not want
to give an extensive
program note to this piece.
I found that very interesting,
and I also noticed
that your piece takes up, unless
it's been changed, one-half of the,
it's after the intermission, and I
was wondering with the commission
from the three organizations,
did you feel you were being
asked for a longer piece?
Could you extend a
little bit what you said,
because I would somewhat be
encouraged, if it's a short piece,
as you said, to hear it
twice here and not, you know,
have to go up to Zurich or to
Brooklyn to hear it a second time.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well, yeah,
strictly speaking the tradition
in these commissioning things is
that the commissioning body by
and large states the instrumentation
which they want you to write for,
not necessarily right down to
the very last guitar string,
but in general terms, and you
know what the ensemble's got.
And the other thing--
yes, duration, thank you,
good Lord, it's been a long week.
[laughter] They also
specify duration.
I had a terrible time with the
Festival De Tante [phonetic]
in Paris three or four years
ago where for one reason
or another the organizer
thought that my piece was two
and a half minutes too short.
[laughter] And got very upset,
and of course if it's going
to be broadcast live on the radio
as in France many things are,
yes what are you going to fill
two and a half minutes with?
But in fact it was
conducted very, very fast.
But that's, you know, the
composer is the always the one
who takes the flack, right.
No, it's interesting though
with contemporary music.
I think we've got pieces
which are very short
in contemporary music
today, and we've got pieces
which are enormously long, and
that wasn't really always the case
in the high, serial
or modernist period.
I think there were many different
approaches we can take now
if feeling our way as it were with
the somatic mechanisms of our body,
the sinews of time, through a
particular sort of argument.
So yes, 20 minutes, where it's
19-1/2 minutes that's one thing.
>> I'm sorry, if I
could just quickly,
could you give us a few
more benchmarks within the--
he talked about there's 12
little things [inaudible] forces.
Can you give us a few other
things [inaudible] through that--
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well
what you'll hear is different,
you'll hear different types of
combinations of instruments.
It's a very colorful ensemble, and
the big challenge was of course
to use two percussionists
because in general the integration
of percussion into chamber music has
always been a somewhat problematic
issue, and when you've got two
of them, then you've really got
to think what it is you're going
to do with them, and so I wanted
to build in the steel drums and
one or two other little things.
So my music, if I use
percussion, my music tends
to change color very quickly.
I don't just stick with
[inaudible] you'll hear all sorts
of things going on, ratchets and
things, which sound rather strange.
So that would be something to
listen to, to try and feel.
The piano is quite
clear, but the percussion
in a sense are a double avatar in
negative if it were, in retrograde,
of what the pianist is doing,
because they are mainly
in the other sections, and so each
of the sections is characterized
by a particular grouping
and strategy
of the percussion instruments
available.
Other things are, for instance,
subsets of the ensemble,
the first appearance of the
second material is actually
for woodwind quintet.
It's not something I think we think
about, but it does happen to be
like that, and that's
the way I planned it.
This is a quite interesting
little poignant fragment
for string quartet
later on in the piece.
Well I'm not sure it's poignant,
but it's string quartet.
[laughter] So it is true that there
are lot of [inaudible] in the piece
where many, many things are
going on at the same time.
I do urge you to look to see how
many instruments are playing,
which instruments are playing.
Certainly with the first material
you'll be able to do that very well,
but with the second, the
argument is a little bit
at an angle if you like.
It's not directly source to ear,
but it's going through a windy sort
of [inaudible] strip type
twisty motion in order
to bring it where it needs to go.
>> David Phylar: Wait until
the-- there's a question up here.
My take away from that also is
that we're owed 30
seconds, is that right?
[laughter]
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Yes.
But I wasn't going to tell you that.
>> David Phylar: Oh it's true.
>> James Baker: I can
add 30 seconds easy.
>> So, you mentioned that
you don't, you don't care
for the culinary analogies
but you've been using a lot
of mathematical and you just
interjected Mobius strip.
Are there any sort of mathematical
cues, themes that you used
in sections of this piece.
>> Brian Ferneyhough:
Well, I do, yes.
This is a problem for you
because you don't get [inaudible].
I work with two screens on my desk.
One is a calculation
screen, which uses Patchwork,
which is a mathematical to
a musical interface program,
and on the right screen is me
writing down the score that results
in [inaudible] original processes.
So, yes. Before about 1992
everything was done by hand.
After that point, [inaudible]
was trying to codify some
of the procedures that
I'd used ad hoc in
earlier pieces as I
cannot [inaudible] in a way
that a computer could
chew on and come
up with many different strategies
[inaudible] as I do do that.
But there aren't many sketches now.
[laughter]
>> So do the musicians kind of
achieve now more than they used
because you have all of these--
I mean the technical
tools could get you
down the rabbit's hole
fairly quickly.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well
when I first started doing
electronic calculations
for my instrumental music, they
said what did you want to do?
I was at Airtime [phonetic] in Paris
at the time, and so we were going
to do a little three
months of [inaudible],
and I said what want this thing to
do is what I've done already by hand
because otherwise how will
I judge it [inaudible]?
You've got to know, you've
got to own the procedures
that you've employed
to get satisfactory,
subjectively satisfactory results.
The only thing that a
program does for you,
it gives you 100 choices instead
of working two weeks
to produce one choice.
And that might be seen to
be somewhat trivializing
of compositional invention,
but I think that's not so.
I mean we always react with some
sort of preferential sensibility
with whatever type of material we've
got [inaudible] I believe in this.
>> David Phylar: There's
another question back there.
>> Thank you.
I'm very much looking
forward to hearing your piece,
as I think we all are, and I also
hear what you said at the beginning
or toward the beginning about
program music and the dang--
I mean of course I understand it's
impossible to produce any piece
of music through an outside program,
and I haven't heard the
piece yet obviously.
That being said, I found
what you did write in terms
of program notes quite fascinating,
and I wanted to offer just a
few comments for your reaction,
even if it's to excoriate
what I'm about to say.
And the first comment I'm
probably much too involved
in the everyday here, but your third
paragraph, and thinking of a person
in Washington, I couldn't
help but be reminded
of our current national
politics to be honest.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well, I
have to emphasize very politely
and certainly respectfully to you
that I am not an American national.
>> Of course, of course.
[laughter] I guess I'm just
relating perhaps somewhat stream
of consciousness how this struck
one American this evening,
and my apologies, you can
excoriate me if you would.
>> Brian Ferneyhough:
No, no, not at all.
I mean I've always
contrived to live in countries
where I never have to vote.
[laughter] There must
be a reason for that.
But this is probably
providing us with more
of a reason than we might like.
May we live in interesting times
of the Chinese [inaudible].
>> Well, in a more general
sense, I mean I'll be interested
to hear this, when you speak
of obstinately pitting two
aggressively distinct musical
character types against each
other, it just makes me wonder
if it's expressive somehow
of the world we're living
in or living through.
Again, probably much
too simplistic, but--
>> Brian Ferneyhough: As I said
earlier on, we like to think
that music has a relevance over
and beyond just making sounds
in the air, like any form of ordered
intellectual or inventive procedure.
I think music surely can
bring forth these things,
but I think it's the
deeper reflection upon what
in the-- okay, [inaudible].
What makes art interesting
is that it deals
with the general in the particular.
So it depends which of these
poles you're going out from.
If you, if you say, okay, all
music should be accessible
because it should be tonal
or it should be modal
or have regular rhythms, well
that's a big general prescription,
but then there's no piece in
the world that could ever live
up to that, to the hundred percent
of those structures because just
for logical reasons that it
would not be an individual piece
if it lived up to all
those structures.
It would be a general
expression of the general.
And a piece of music is always
internally dissonant in the sense
that those general aspects should
ideally inform our listening
to some extent, but it's the
particularities of the work
which lend wings to the retention
and reworking of those impressions
after the piece is finished.
And I think it is very important,
rather like a perspectival
vanishing point,
sometimes the vanishing point
could be off the compass,
it could be somewhere else.
Or if you've got a fragment
where the arm is missing,
you can extrapolate the arm but
not exactly where the arm was
but the sort of armness
of that situation.
So, yet, of course I believe
there are general things
which will allow the individualness
and to confront certain aspects
of present day experience but
at the same time it wouldn't be
of any value.
I could write an article for
Time Magazine now I suppose
if I did not compose music.
If you didn't [inaudible],
the largely passive background
of generality with
the very [inaudible]
and specific invention
of a particular piece.
>> You said it much
better than I could,
and thank you for indulging me.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well greater
length and I'm sorry about that.
>> No, thank you for indulging me.
>> David Phylar: We'll take one
or two more questions [inaudible].
>> Hi.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Hey.
>> So, correct me if I'm wrong,
I know you've done a piece or two
at least for-- that
involved electronics--
am I correct to say
that you have not
yet done strictly electro-acoustic
composition?
>> Brian Ferneyhough: No.
>> No, I'm sorry.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: No,
in fact, how would you know?
>> Okay, well I--
>> Brian Ferneyhough: I had the word
about five to six years ago I did,
I finally decided that
whilst I didn't want
to do extremely sophisticated
electronic generation using god
knows how much software, what I
did was I gathered together all the
dreadful deadbeat programs you can
get off the Internet free of charge
and wrote music using only those.
[laughter] So, yes, some of
it's pretty gruesome, but it's--
one of them has been played
in public several times.
One of them only at Stanford in one
of their Friday afternoon
weirdness sessions.
[laughter] I wouldn't call myself
an electronic composer though.
I mean I do sell electronics in
other pieces, like a chorale piece,
which is part of the opera, in
which the singing triggers attacks
of different types of sonic material
as the piece goes on transforming
into the voice so that
the two come together
in a sort of [inaudible] flow.
>> The reason I ask
is because I know
that your music is highly specific
rhythmically, and I would think
that with the emergence of
electronics this allows for that
to be much, for your music to
be performed with perfection.
Do you, perhaps the reason that you
might not do strictly electronic
music is because you
like the concept
of the performers having the, I
guess, I don't know, you might want
to a struggle, or the
human aspect to it.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well,
I don't like word perfection.
I think that was a scientificist
view of the 1950's and early '60's
in America, a sort of subclass
of the European serial system,
which came to reside in
American Universities only
because the people concerned could
convince the appointment committees
that these were objectively
valuable principles, yes?
So, it's a pity, but that
in fact was what happened.
So, whew, [inaudible] perfection.
What would be a perfect rendition?
I don't believe that there is
such a thing first of all, and B,
I think this is something,
you know, we've talked about,
the fidelity to the intention of the
piece rather than precise rendition
of what's there is what
we're really talking about.
It's something which has a surplus
of energizing potential over
and beyond the mere replicative.
There was a piece, an Italian
piece years ago by [inaudible],
and we don't need to
say any more about it,
but he called it Phil
Aleza [phonetic] [singing],
and he [inaudible] and you see
this incredibly contorted, sick,
quasi-serial, multiple
irrational values piled up on top
of each other, tempo changes every
two beats, and it seems like this,
what he was doing was very clever.
He had taken a recording of
an interpretation [inaudible]
and he had transcribed
it as best he could
into contemporary musical notation.
All the notes were
exactly in the place
where the performer
was playing them.
So [singing], so what is it we
interpreted in the Beethoven piece?
We interpret 20 generations
of Beethoven [inaudible].
No reason that's not a good thing.
That's why tradition in
the arts is very powerful.
So just because you see a notation
that is very exact, it doesn't mean
that I'm looking for that
sort of scientific exactitude
because I don't think that my mind
at least works in that
particular way.
It works in a sort of
Gestalt [phonetic] way.
You put things together
because they belong together
under generalized rules no
doubt from Gestalt philosophy
which would allow us to examine
that, but I don't bother.
I just write the music.
So yeah, perfect no.
You know, the exhilaration of a
live performance is always something
which is totally different from the
studio recordings I'm sure you're
aware, and once they have
their benefits indeed,
I'm happy to take whatever
circumstance
or incidentalities apply in
a live performance anytime.
>> David Phylar: Thank you.
Let's just take one last question.
>> My sense is that
your piece is written
out exactly the way you want it,
there's not chance
elements or anything in it.
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well
only so far as any music,
any human activity is shock
through with chance element.
No, there were no, everything
is precisely notated.
>> And one other question
which as you mentioned
that there is some microtonal--
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Yes.
>> -- elements in it, and I
was wondering what the purpose
of that was because some
people use that for the purpose
of approximating just
intonation or--
>> Brian Ferneyhough: Well, you
know, there were different sorts
of microtones and they make
possible different sorts
of realistically attainable results.
Quarter tones are usually pretty
good as long as you don't try
to sing a small perfect fifth.
I mean it's just-- I had
a pupil once in a course.
He came with a piece
for four singers.
And he had written it
in 24 tones [inaudible],
and there was absolutely no way
that you were going to sing a C here
and an F three-quarter
[inaudible] there.
It just doesn't work
that way for our ears.
We're not constructed that way.
So you can do a 12-tone piece,
but you can't do a 24-tone
piece, and that's the reason.
So what you've got to do is
to decide where the limit is,
in other words not where
you don't use microtones,
but you have to decide, it's a
sort of cost effect analysis.
You have to.
If you've got a 12-tone piece, which
goes ding, ding, ding, ding, ding,
ding, do, do, do, do, lo, lo, do.
Well yes, you hear
the first five sounds,
but you don't hear the last seven
sounds, but they're still part
of the 12-tone note structure.
So whilst it seems to be an
objective method [inaudible] method,
our ears don't deal with
those seven notes the same way
as they do the five notes,
and that's exactly true
of microtonal writing.
So it's incumbent upon the composer
in my view to provide a sort
of rough and ready scale
of a possible appreciation
for microtonal writing.
And so I said, the piano here,
or the keyboard, does use third
and sixth terms, and these
are very natural intervals
in the overtone series, but
they don't sound natural
when you put them on a keyboard.
So what shall I say,
goal-directed defamiliarization.
[laughter]
[ Applause ]
>> David Phylar: On that note,
I'd like to thank all of you
for attending this talk and
for the good questions and also
if you could join me in thanking
Brian Ferneyhough and James Baker.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.